let's talk about conflict of interest
so you said you could advertise public
you have a popular twitter account
it's
it's hilarious and insightful
uh you do promote bitcoin
in a sense i don't know if you would say
that
but do you think there's a conflict of
interest in anyone who owns bitcoin
promoting bitcoin is it the same as you
promoting the farming
i would say no
there's an interest
i think that
i think that um you can promote
a property
or an idea
to the extent that you don't control it
i think that the point at which you
start to have
a conflict of interest is when you're
promoting a proprietary product or
proprietary security a security in
general's proprietary asset so for
example if you look at my twitter
you will find that i make lots of
statements about bitcoin you won't ever
see me making a statement that say
microstrategy stock will go off forever
right i'm not promoting a security mstr
because at the end of the day mstr is a
security it is proprietary i have
proprietary interest in it i have
a disproportionate amount of control and
influence on the direction
where controls the problem the control
is the problem because you have interest
in both
you can very if bitcoin is as successful
as we're talking about you are very
possibly can become the richest human on
earth
given how much you own in bitcoin right
the wealthiest not the richest i don't
know what those words mean
i would benefit economically economic
you would benefit economically that's
true so the
the reason that's not conflict of
interest is because
uh
the word property
that bitcoin is an idea and
it's big points
i don't control it in essence the the
the ethical line here
is could i print myself 10 million more
bitcoin or not
right i i can anyone right it's not just
you it's it can can anyone
because can you promote somebody else's
yes i guess you can
like if you can you can promote uh
apple
you could have a twitter account where
you promote oil or you promote camping
or you promote family values or promote
you know a carnivore diet or promote the
iron man right that those are not going
to get wealthier if you promote
camping
because you can't own a steak and i mean
you own a lot of bitcoin what is that
what is that what the game don't you own
at the stake in the idea
yeah i would i would grant you that
but the lack of control
is the fundamental ethical line that you
just you don't have
all you are is you're a fan of the idea
you believe in the idea and the power of
the idea
yeah i think you can't take that idea
away from others
let's come back to let me give you some
maybe easier examples if you were the
head of the marine corps
right
and uh
and someone came to you and said i
created marine corn
and uh and the twist on marine coin is
is i want you to tell every marine that
they'll get an extra marine coin you
know
when they when they get their next
stripe
and then i'm going to give you you know
i'm going to let you buy marine coin now
and then after you buy marine coin i
want you to like uh promote it
to them
right
at some point
if if you start to have a
disproportional influence on it or if
you're in a conversation with people
with disproportionate influence becomes
conflict of interest and it would make
you profoundly uncomfortable i think
yeah if the head of the marine corps
started promoting anything that looked
like a security
now if the head of the marine corps
started promoting canoeing
you might think he's kind of wacky like
maybe
like that's kind of a waste of time a
distraction so
but but
but to the extent that
canoeing is not a security not a problem
unless you you know
ultimately the the issue of
decentralization is really a critical
not having a head one so is is it
something
can bitcoin
be replicated
so the all the things that you're saying
that make it a property can that be
replicated have any other possible to
create other
crypto properties does it does the
having a head
like of a project
a thing that limits its ability to be a
property if you if you try to replicate
a project
is that the fundamental flaw i look i
think the real fundamental issue is you
just never want it to change
like like uh
if you really want something
decentralized
you want a genetic template that
substantially is not going to change for
a thousand years so i think satoshi said
it at one point he said the nature of
the software is such that by version .1
its genetic code was set
if if there was any development team
that's continually changing it you know
on a routine basis it becomes harder and
harder
to maintain its decentralization because
now now there's the issue of who's
influencing
the changes
you